unlv graduating seniors can down their
caps and gowns
in person that decision made following
the recent trend of numbers
nevada's test positivity rate still just
above 5 percent
the last time we saw that number that
low was late june 2020
cases up more than 240 statewide but
that number is still very low when
compared to the last several months
where we're having
three four thousand cases a day eight
news now reporter sasha loftis joining
us now with more on sasha there's got to
be an air of excitement
about that big decision
brian yes the students we spoke with
here on campus today said they were
absolutely ecstatic
to hear this news they just really
absolutely can't wait to walk across
that stage and
celebrate in person with friends and
family safely
gabby delong can barely contain her
excitement
i started crying because i was so happy
she's one of many unlv seniors
celebrating after news broke friday that
the school will hold
its may graduation ceremonies in person
i called my grandma
and she was ecstatic she started cry too
my dad was super happy
executive vice president and provost
chris heavey says
this decision has been months in the
making and they're working with the
state and county
to keep everyone safe we believe that
you know with fairly high confidence now
that we'll be able to do this safely and
a fitting marking of their achievement
the outdoor ceremonies will allow
graduates to receive their diplomas in a
socially distant setting
with family and friends cheering from
the sidelines
we salute you for having hung in there
through this
most challenging year that any of us
have really experienced in our lifetimes
and having achieved your college degree
it's been a long
challenging road and students like gabby
weren't so sure they'd get here
i miss seeing my professors in person
and my friends and all of that stuff
but she says she's so grateful for this
new sense of normalcy
she'll remember forever we did it guys
now this year's ceremonies are set for
may 14th and 15th that's a friday and
saturday
it is a ticketed event and of course
masks are required for
everyone attending we're also told each
student is allowed to invite
up to four people brian since the class
of 2020
couldn't have that in person graduation
will they be included in these
ceremonies
brian yes unlv will have a special
ceremony for the 2020 graduates that's
on the 14th
at 6 30 p.m we're told that the
registrar here
at unlv will reach out to all of those
2020 graduates
and graduates coming up this 2021 school
year
in the coming weeks reporting live
tonight at unlv sasha loftis
8 news now great news for both those
classes thanks sasha